BRUCE KERR-PETERSON: Hello, my
name is Bruce Kerr-Peterson.
I'm the EMEA lead for
the AdWords platform.
My team and I work with actually
quite a few of you already.
But we work with you on user
acquisition and engagement
campaigns through AdWords.
So this is all the
paid advertising,
which I'm sure you're
all looking forward to.
So to kick us off, this
is a lightning session.
So I'm going to be covering
a few topics-- maximizing
your user engagement through our
different channels, retention
and lifetime value, as well as
data insights and management.
So we did a brief
study of some users
to ask them what ads prompted
them to download an app.
And not too surprisingly,
50% of the users
were prompted to download
an app from a search ad.
This is followed by the
middle two, which is basically
running campaigns on our AdMob
and mobile web channels, so
display network,
and lastly video ads
through channels
such as YouTube.
We know that video has
been traditionally more
of an awareness
type of campaign.
We expect this to
change going forward
with a few new releases
coming out hopefully
towards the end of this year.
So let's kick it off.
We're absolutely
delighted with the launch
of search ads in Play.
We have seen fantastic
results-- although it's
very early days-- with
increased volume, low CPIs.
And the user quality is
absolutely fantastic.
The campaigns are really
easy to set up as well.
All you have to do is go
into the AdWords interface,
create a search campaign,
set up with a few keywords--
and if you're stuck for keywords
there's a keyword suggestion
tool-- and run
Conversion Optimizer.
Conversion Optimizer optimizes
toward the target CPI
that you choose.
Your ads will then show across
google.com and the Play store,
driving people to
actually install your ads.
It's a very simple
campaign structure.
And the performance, once
again, has been fantastic.
One of our bread
and butter channels
is acquiring users through
AdMob and mobile web.
We know this has
been performing well.
It's two channels
that really drive
a lot of volume and reach.
Once again, the set-up is easy.
You upload a few text ads.
We would encourage
you to use video.
Video interstitials have a
far higher conversion rate.
You target run of network and
allow Conversion Optimizer
to find the best uses for
you at your target CPI.
And finally, YouTube-- as I
mentioned a few slides back,
YouTube has traditionally been
an awareness type of channel.
However, what we've
seen is that you
can get phenomenal results
and highly engaged users.
And hopefully with the launch
of Conversion Optimizer
towards the end of
this year, we'll
be able to scale user
acquisition at a target CPI
across YouTube,
qualifying the users
before they download your app.
So if you had to run each of
these channels individually,
this is the standard
campaign structure and set-up
we would recommend to
be able to maximize
each one of these channels.
So we would suggest,
firstly, making sure
your measurement was all set up,
whether that be with an AdWords
SDK or third party
tracking, and then
starting off with our two main
networks and channels-- display
and search.
These two have
performed considerably
over the past couple of months.
And we're very confident
that they work very well.
So you would start off
with those two campaigns.
You can optimize your
search campaigns in week two
by adding a few more keywords
once you've got performance.
And once those two
are up and running,
then you can experiment by
running YouTube campaigns,
trying to get a bit
more incremental reach,
starting with similar
lists to make sure
that your targeting is tight.
So we understand that
traditional performance
marketing has been focused
on optimizing each one
of these channels individually.
And for some companies,
that's the right way to go.
And for a lot of others,
it's incredibly time
consuming and very,
very difficult to do.
So I'm absolutely
delighted as well
with the launch of
Universal App Campaigns.
It actually fully
rolls out today.
There will be a press release
later on this afternoon.
And what it enables you to
do, as Miles pointed out,
is to target across all the
different networks through one
simple campaign flow.
The campaign flows
as easy as this.
There are three steps to it.
Firstly, you have to
upload a few lines of text,
a few different variations
of text, and a video.
And if you have
image ads, you can
import your locations,
language, budget,
and target cost per install.
And then ultimately you have
to just enable the campaign
and it will run across
all of Google's channels,
targeting app install imagery.
This is what the
interface will look like.
As you can see on
the left hand side,
there are four different
variations of text,
allowing Conversion Optimizer
to optimize and choose
the best one.
You can input a YouTube URL, and
it'll pull your YouTube video
in directly.
And on the right
hand side, you can
see that your app icon and
images are automatically
pulled in through Google Play.
So optimizing those is
obviously very important.
Once you enable those campaigns,
it's really straightforward.
Your ads, your bids,
your banner distribution,
and your targeting are all
optimized automatically.
We aim to get you the maximum
volume at your target CPI.
The initial beta testing
of this has been fantastic,
and we're delighted that
it's rolling out today.
It will hopefully make your
lives a lot easier when
it comes to user acquisition.
Underlying all of
this, as I said before,
is data and insights.
You can use some of
Google's solutions,
such as integrating the AdWords
SDK to track your conversions
and measure them, and Analytics
for measuring in-app activity.
Or alternatively, as many of
you do work with a third party,
let us know, as we have
close relationships
with most of the third
party tracking companies.
Why do we measure?
Of course, this is
paid advertising.
So you've got to make sure
that your average LTV is
greater than your average CPI.
We know that one
out of six users
don't make a purchase
within an app.
And we know that 80% of
users only use an app once
after installing it.
So app economics
works when you know
the lifetime value of your app.
And then you work
with the channel
to acquire users
that are low value.
So when we talk
about lifetime value,
this is a very,
very simple example.
But this is something that,
as an advertising channel,
we need to understand from you.
What actual values are
users bringing to you?
So if we look at a very basic
case of a user over one year,
or a set of users
over a year, we
can see that a user might
have paid $5 on average
within your app
to purchase items.
Perhaps you have
an offline store,
and they made an
additional $5 purchase
throughout the year
in that offline store.
And we know that those users,
through reviews and ratings
and messaging apps,
spread your app to others.
So there's an uplift
from word of mouth.
So if we estimate that
on average your users are
worth $11 to you a
year, then we know
that we have to pay less than
that to acquire them for you
to be ROI positive.
So once we have
identified what we're
willing to pay for
a user, we have
to figure out how we can
maximize their lifetime value
and drive engagement.
The clicker seems to
be very stubborn today.
There we go.
So we surveyed
another set of users
to understand why
they like using apps
and what key commercial
activities they use apps for.
And you can see there
that, across the funnel,
they like using apps for
multiple different things,
everything from reading
reviews by others
all the way through
to royalty programs
at the end of the funnel.
So if you know by
speaking to your users
and by looking at your analytics
what users do within your app,
you're able to then create
engagement campaigns to try
and drive them into
that part of the funnel
that they enjoy most.
There are two ways in which you
can create engagement campaigns
at the moment.
The simplest and easiest
is auto-created lists.
So all you have to do here is
link your Google Play account
to you AdWords account.
And there are a number
of auto-generated lists
that you can re-market to
with specific messaging.
This is the best and
easiest way to try this out
to see if you can
generate value.
If you get that
right, then you can
start looking at custom
lists where you can either
import lists from Google
Analytics, Service Server,
or third party integration.
So once you've
created your list,
you understand what
your users like,
the last piece is tailoring
messaging to them.
So three examples of messages
that you can tailor to them--
if you're trying to
get users to engage
with your app, the
first thing to do
is to deliver to
all of them content
that can only be accessed
or engaged with in the app.
The second messaging
is for users
who may have lapsed and
stopped using your app,
and you want to
get them back in.
The best way to
do this is to let
them know that there are
new features within your app
that they can take
advantage if they reengage.
And finally what
we see often, is
people start purchasing
items, get to their cart,
and then abandon the cart.
You can target those
users specifically
by offering them a
discount that might
be only applicable
on that day to get
them to complete that purchase.
So as you can see, we've got
two main takeaways today.
First, search ads in Play--
fantastic results initially.
And as of today will be
the launch of universal app
campaigns, which will
hopefully streamline and make
your user acquisition
campaigns far easier.
So if you want to chat
about this, let me know.
I'll be around.
And enjoy the rest of your day.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]